the gyro can experience said OB lady in
was it Louisiana she got bit by an
alligator she's trying to take a picture
with it
it's like closer to him and the
alligator ate her did you say derp is on
it's on camera it's on camera but you
know it's pretty rare than an alligator
attacks and kills a person people think
I'm closer those rattlesnakes when I
post a picture of them but the video of
them but I'm assuming I'm actually good
and my bike's always between me and the
rattlesnake usually it's just brought
over his head flattening out hold on
yeah but then I thought someone sent me
a video of a guy running over one and it
you know even though he ran over it is
so big it turned back and bit his [ __ ]
calf really yeah even though it was like
oh bit his ass oh I could see that
happen yes yeah some boys are thick they
[ __ ] they flex they flex all that muscle
and then well he probably tried to be a
[ __ ] and run over the back of it you
had [ __ ] [ __ ] heads without dark
they are man oh man they're a dangerous
creature ever seen one dragging a rabbit
it's nuts they're monsters my kid it's
not good it's like four four I'm the
fast boy in the world yeah dude you keep
saying that man and he is he's the fast
four-year-old you've ever seen before
year-olds aren't rattlesnakes dude
that's hilarious
he's he's big all the calves he got from
his mama he's also shredded fast boy in
the world all right man some kids are
just jacked when they're young and you
realize that life isn't fair you look at
some kids and look like they're
literally made out of marshmallows like
marshmallows covered by a thin it's a
bomber thin skin it's a bum like did you
see that that five year old that stole
the car to go buy a Lamborghini this
five year old stole the car and when you
see me like well that's the biggest
five-year-old in the world
he's probably I don't know 100 he's so
fat look at him they put a weird thing
over his face oh so you can't see him
but there's video of his family talking
they're all thick as [ __ ] and he stole
this car cuz mom Tommy can't have a
Lamborghini five-year-old driving an SUV
on a Utah freeway and then he
I'm going to California buy a
Lamborghini you how much money have you
guys I have three dollars in my wallet
so look at this they spotted the vehicle
driver 35 miles an hour and swerving
this five-year-old is just driving on
the highway that's an what a confident
kid they pulled over and not bad and not
bad for a five-year-old and he's gonna
put on the brakes just how crazy how old
are you five
you're five years old Wow his sister
fell asleep while she's babysitting so
he just you stole a car yeah cuz I guess
before his mom left it work he's like
haven't Lamborghini she's according to
[ __ ] mind now he's like three dollars
with him and he was going to buy a
Lamborghini this is like a Will Ferrell
movie it's insane
but not bad for a five-year-old did you
see that that big baby - that mean I was
gonna round this gigantic baby it's
about three years old I think what's
yeah what is that thing
Danny likes creepiest [ __ ] that's a
weird that's like a adult pretending to
be he's a weird kid
god dammit [ __ ] is thick Jesus Christ
yeah
this giant babies never really ends well
for him does it doesn't end well for
Giants mom of big baby tells haters he's
actually healthy mmm we started going
around doing that I felt after just like
this is the next NFL like lineman he
might be might be a giant might be
[Applause]